[Music]
welcome back to football season
everybody it is you man the LEF koe and
I say it's football season cuz I just
watched a video of the homie Travis
Kelce walking down the football field
and Patrick mahomes runs and jumps on
his back dappin up and just makes you
realize when the football players are
excited to see each other in Jalen
Ramsey is showing up at an Adidas Brinks
truck and and the players are showing up
to can football is back and it feels so
good you are about to be inundated in
the next two weeks with more news
stories than you know how to handle the
NFL social media spree has changed so
much in these last few years with roto
world and bleach to report and oh and
all of these reporters tweeting more and
instagramming more I'm telling you five
years ago they said I am saving my
information for my article that comes
out in the newspaper
not anymore you're gonna get five guys
the New Orleans Saints could cut after
one practice you're gonna get six
rookies that are gonna blow your face
off after one training camp it is gonna
be insane and so I'm telling you that
the next two weeks it's gonna be
overload you're like me you want to be a
breast of all the situation you want to
know all the information across the NFL
most of the information that you're
going to hear is not going to matter I'm
here for you okay I'm gonna try and keep
track of all of it there's gonna be a
lot of whoa big offseason and it really
pops the next few weeks the next few
weeks you're gonna start getting
articles about hometowns the guy that
might miracle make the team as the
eighth tight end you're gonna get those
stories the only thing I ask of you is
when you see it tweet it at the left go
show and use whoa big offseason let's
let everybody know what the craziness is
this guy comes in great shape this guy
comes in vegan it's gonna be I'm just
I'm already seeing the tweets and the
pop-ups and those are wild woes however
there is no there's no fake woes here
we're gonna have an interview with Mike
Vrabel head coach of the Tennessee
Titans we got out there at Tahoe it was
right after he did this podcast with his
offensive lineman Taylor lawanda and
we'll Compton bust him with the boys I'm
gonna say the name of their podcast
where they asked they asked if he would
cut his dick off too in a Super Bowl
I had follow-up questions that's coming
up in just a bit and then also color the
all-pro cornerback for the Chicago Bears
I spotted him on the green and it was
the only guy I didn't know who he was
and I admitted it to him that interview
coming up at the end of the podcast we
do have some news that I know a lot of
you are curious about the fantasy league
for the podcast last year 396 of you
signed up we had 28 conferences meatloaf
ran 'it's the winner of all those
conferences played in one super week to
find a champion to be crowned on the
podcast meatloaf has moved on meatloaf
we love you I hope you do well in all
your endeavors and that means that I am
passing it along to the super Saints fan
the teen with a dream William ezel and I
feel confident giving it to him even
though he was a young whippersnapper
with his own podcast because in his
Instagram bio it says proud member of
the 33% love it god bless among the
members of BR gridiron if you're not
following be our gridiron on social
media you're missing out it is gonna be
the place that you need to go in
addition to the left coast show accounts
to keep up with the cool moments of the
NFL and we've come up with a name we
were trying to figure out how do I get
the left coast show how do we get
fantasy in there how do we get be our
gridiron in there and Ingmar had the
great idea it's going to be known as the
left go fantasy gridiron league why
cuz that's lfg l let's [ __ ] go so if
you would have called the left go
fantasy gridiron league awesome I'm
gonna kind of be calling it the lfg
League let's [ __ ] go because I'm so
excited I am going to work the next few
days to figure out the scheduling I'm
gonna work with ezel to figure out when
do we need to have our drafts I am
someone that likes to have the draft
after the third preseason game I do not
like drafting before then I don't want
guys getting hurt but we're gonna have
to come up with commissioners so I'm
gonna put out a form that I'm gonna work
with ezel if you want to be a
commissioner stay on the lookout in
social Lefko show instagram and twitter
we're gonna we're gonna see who wants to
be the commissioners how many people are
gonna come into the league and then you
guys are gonna have to set up your own
drafts so I appreciate you guys so much
it's gonna be a lot of fun I will have a
team I will be competing in one of the
league's and whoever is the grand
champion will get interviewed on the pod
one other little news and notes I don't
know if you guys have done this yet go
to pod thoughts Campillo d and the word
thoughts th o u GH TS calm take a
listener survey this is just for us to
get a better idea of of what you think
about the show and it's gonna help us
figure out advertising that you guys
actually want to hear so go to pod
thoughts comm take the listener survey
it would really help the show but we
want you to mention it directly the left
coast show there was some news today
Mike Daniels released from the Green Bay
Packers I'm shocked I'm not gonna lie
when I picked the Packers to win the a
the NFC North one of the main reasons
was what they have on their defensive
line because I thought with Kenny Clark
Mike Daniels they just went out there
and got Preston Smith Siderius Smith
they drafted were Shawn Geary in the top
15 picks and when this place is loaded
and so for him to report and get cut is
kind of shocking to me he's also been a
representative for that team for a long
time Joe banner the
former GM of eagles and the Browns came
out and said let's be perfectly clear
the releasing of veteran players on the
eve of training camp is wrong and
indefensible defensible unless there
were circumstances we are unaware of and
have been clearly clearly explained to
the player and agent it's just wrong
I talked to some Packers fans in the
office and they talked about how he did
have a leg injury last year and maybe it
carried over I start to wonder did he
show up out of shape is he not is this
is his injury still an issue did he Park
in Matt Lafleur spot did he fart near
Aaron Rodgers and it got him upset did
he tell Davante Adams he's not the best
dunker in the NFL I don't know but I
agree with Joe I don't know why this is
happening right now why would it happen
at this point and not give someone that
the coach comes out and says he's been
advocate for the team the chance to see
free agency I don't get him but I do
think as I see Adam Schefter say his
preference is to sign with a Super Bowl
contender I have five teams that I think
he should be looking at I do not know of
these teams have the salary cap to sign
him I was I was like oh the Bucks could
use him but they're not a real Super
Bowl contender but the five teams I came
out with were Rams because as I said
before when you look at the Rams front
seven it's a little underwhelming and if
you put Mike Daniels next to Aaron
Donald suddenly a front four of Dante
Fowler Aaron Donald Mike Daniels and
Michael brokers looks really good I put
the Vikings in there because every
Packer seems to move on and go to the
Vikings not just pret Favre there's been
a ton of them but I also think that they
have depth issues on that D line in
Minnesota and just like Gerald McCoy
went to the Panthers to play the Bucs
twice a year cutting in this late in the
game I'm sure Mike Daniels like I'd love
to rub it into the Packers Seahawks need
some help remember - Ron Reed just got
suspended six games and I thought they
were a little shallow anyway he is from
New Jersey and I don't think the Giants
are an option and the Jets because of
the three-four I don't think
they're an option either Patriots are an
option you look at the Patriots right
now we know that they're gonna find ways
to rotate people in there and take care
of it
but the same point Lawrence Kai and
Danny Shelton I know they got Michael
Bennett but they have a lot of medium
guys I know they took a draft pick on
chase vinovich but look if you're
winning looking to win a Super Bowl I
understand if you go sign with the
Patriots and the other team for me is
the Falcons I know I'm a little bit
higher on them that a lot of people but
looking at their D line him next to
Grady Jarrett would be pretty
unbelievable and and I think it would
help out Vic Beasley to try and get
something out of him it would move Sanat
to more of a role player role which is
where I think he should be I just look
at those five teams as teams that I
think would make sense if he went
factoring in the fact that Adam Schefter
said he wants to play for a Super Bowl
champion but then will big offseason who
doesn't want to play for a Super Bowl
champion all right we're gonna get to
why i did not like Jalen Ramsey's
entrance to training camp an inside look
at top 10 Jersey sales and then again
we're gonna have Kyle fuller coming up
but first let's talk about chopping off
your penis to win a Super Bowl with the
head coach of the Tennessee Titans Mike
Vrabel something just came on my tweets
that I'm very excited to talk to you
about wheat you did a podcast oh here we
go with Taylor LaJuan and the boys
compton yeah and you would cut your dick
off for a Super Bowl so how do we do
this well I've I don't know I don't know
who would tell me when to do it but I
know that my wife would be the first in
line to to do the do so to the deed
really she would take care of it for us
she would make sure it's like clean
you sanitary sometimes you come home and
I'm not always as cheery as I probably
should be but no those guys I'm proud of
those guys for doing that my vision it
put the bus together and it's fun it's
cool and you know I'm proud of them you
know I'm proud of them for doing
something outside of football and you
know with it you know what it's like to
be on there and also when I have a
personality and kind of do your own
thing yeah you have to be able to to be
yourself I don't understand that you
know Will's not on our team anymore but
him and you know Taylor obviously they
got big personalities they're funny and
you have to it's a long season training
camps along the seasons long you have to
have guys in there that can cut it up
all life actuate about you man is you're
able to connect with these guys like was
that did you know you wanted to be coach
right away ah well it took me nine years
you graduate from Ohio State so I don't
know what else I'm cut out to do you
know I was playing and I was going back
to school and just really felt like I
had a lot of great mentors or game that
that taught me how to play sure know how
to be a parent how to be a father
husband all those things and a coach and
try to help those guys cuz I can't do it
any more clearly and so if I can try to
do anything to help those guys do their
job when you see people reacting to you
like running before the game and they're
going man this dude could still play
yeah you know I think that that's that's
the easy answer there's no way I'm the
first one to tell you
but I can't do it they would whip me I
would enjoy you know when I get out
there with him I think they enjoy taking
shots at me and oh yeah that's okay
you know I mean I don't mind it I'll
I'll do it until until they hurt me if I
were to rank the coaches in terms of
their ability to like win a Royal Rumble
you're undoubtedly in the top five
Brian Flores has made his way in there I
think you know you take him out I would
put you I'm gonna take number one me why
you just reacted to that I don't know
really
you're more of a top three guy maybe
flow I mean great guy I just feel like
maybe I be giving up 50 pounds to me I
mean how long madder than hell right now
I think that and and pound well that's
what your team is all about what are you
is this your - now for you yep year -
how much easier is it not well you know
it's always hard to win games in this
league I know that that sounds but I I
think that doing it the second time
around you kind of know where the speed
bumps are you know what a potholes are
it's like coming home from work the same
way you know exactly where the traffic
so high that a lot what are the potholes
in your first year that you would like
look back and go well I mean just just
the way that injuries happen and having
a plan and you always want to have a
schedule and you think about the
schedule and how things work and are we
you know when do we leave to get to the
hotel
when does the flight leave a lot of
those things when do we eat how much
time do we have between practice and
meetings you know just always worrying
about looking at it from a perspective
of a player you know I know that when I
played and you had the last meeting in
practice so I give these guys 45 minutes
I know they're going here take a dump
it runs if something eat so I'm trying
to make them rush so I say we'll have 45
minutes we'll make it up somewhere else
so you know you're just trying to look
at it from the eyes of a player and what
their normal day would look like so I've
always thought the most frustrating
thing as a coach is definitely the media
take
your [ __ ] and taking a different
direction and what I thought is like
your the situation right now where
people are asking you about Marcus and
I'm going what Marcus has done the
playoffs how Marcus carries himself the
way the rest of the team like I've met a
lot of your players and the way they
speak about Marcus is like with love and
admiration and it's this thing where I'm
going
why does variable need to get out there
and say Marcus is the guy I I don't even
get it you know I think it's easy you
know our fans want to know about our
quarterback you want to know about the
star players and that's that's what we
have to do and I myself to the fact that
I try to have a relationship with our
local media they're great I mean I did
an event for Special Olympics and
February Polar Plunge and I was joking
around and you know talking about hey
want to see if when these guys could
swim and see how long I could hold them
under water and then one thing led to
another and we ended up having 10 or 12
local media members come out raise some
money for Special Olympics do the Polar
Plunge yeah so I'm trying to do my best
I'm talk to these people I meet with
them more than I do my own wife and kids
every single day throughout this
training camp and the season so trying
to just get the norm as people they're
family and they had a job to do I
respect their job and you know they can
ask anything they want it's up to me to
answer it our one I've been very
impressed with you men I'm super happy
with how the teams kind of developing
stuff and like just you being a head
coach it's been a lot of fun it has been
fun for me we got great guys they play
hard that's the one thing that has a
coach you you really understand means a
lot when another guy that you respect
another coach who respects this man your
guys play hard and that's the different
coaches you know different coaches in
the league and that that's the that's
the greatest compliment a coach could
ever receive not that you have great
plays or you know this or you're good
value it's that you guys play hard
the whole thing before yep when you
change an offensive coordinator it's
kind of an opportunity as a head coach
to kind of say this is what I want this
is the flow that I want this I like my
team makeup what did you what did you
pass on in that with the noise
well I think that Arthur gonna bring a
lot of continuity I think into the
second year I just felt like we got to
the details of the plays on offense and
defense and special teams much quicker
than we did last year gotcha
last year was like man where do I lineup
what's my job now it's we could get into
the maybe somebody made a nice little
house and get into the details of hey
how do you do your job better and bring
the picture to life I'm tuning them yes
which player do you think that helps the
most with just the continuity like is
there is there a receiver Titan that you
think was really starting to come on on
the end last year well I mean I think
that we've gotten a lot of good work out
of tarjay and Taiwan and those guys
we're pushing each other and they tell
ya they complement each other today's
you know a long linear guy up really
good hands and you know take and take
the top off of it so we just have to
keep working and progressing with those
guys and and continue to help us and
then Corey Davis is still you know going
into his third year so those are the
skill guys that hopefully that
continuity continues to to help but and
really for everybody
protection wise oh line defensive line
linebackers how we're gonna play its
coverage you know you just get into the
details if you were in the Super Bowl
I'm gonna assume that you've cut your
dick off well for able I hope so you're
the man you hope so I hope we don't have
to wear as a coach inside there is
something special in the Super Bowl
should we both color our dicks off
that's up to you
did you notice how upset variable got
when I said that maybe Flores could beat
him in a Royal Rumble unbelievable he
got offended he was like I would kick
his ass it's not even an option
fraggle variable wasn't a very good mood
and I kept talking to him afterwards he
was like just shut up Adam and I was
like all right I probably went too far
there but he's awesome
all right so the top 10 Jersey sales
came out in the NFL and what since
there's a few things interesting to me
I'm gonna run through one through ten
Brady Odell khalil Mack Sam darn old
Baker Mayfield Patrick mahomes Aaron
Rodgers Antonio Brown Zeke and se Kwang
a lot of these make sense they're like
if you were to tell me these are the top
10 most popular players the NFL I'd say
I completely agree
I'd say JJ Watts probably in there but
that right there is a good list of young
guys with a lot of panache that have a
lot of sauce and that I could see them
being popular few things that caught my
eye
one five quarterbacks I usually feel
like these lists are packed with
quarterbacks but the non quarterbacks
Odell Mack Antonio Brown Zeke and sake
one that shows you in my opinion so much
about the fan bases O'Dell new team
Antonio Brown new team mahomes Baker
sand Arnold Zeke say Kwan all up not not
Zeke say Kwan all up and coming second
year guys maybe people didn't get the
jerseys yet Mack I look at it and I go
new guy but also Chicago has a huge fan
base it makes sense what's shocking to
me is Tom Brady at number one and Aaron
Rodgers at number seven Tom Brady is 58
years old I just don't understand where
all of these new Tom Brady jersey sales
are coming from like are there people
that are like you know what now I think
he's gonna be the guy now you know what
now it's okay to spend my money and get
a Jersey are they are they like kids
jerseys that were like buying like I
just thought that if you were a Patriots
fan or a Tom Brady fan you would have
gotten that Jersey by now and I just
think it's crazy that he's number one
like Odell Beckham goes to the Browns so
you have these Odell fans and these
Browns fans like there's a reason to
have this burst in Jersey sales
same thing with Sam dartle oh you know
what he looked at his first year I'm
gone
on Sam Baker patcher moms he won the MVP
I'm going in on it the fact that Aaron
Rodgers is in the top ten and Tom Brady
is number one I just don't know who is
just deciding to buy a Tom Brady Jersey
that it's I get it I love Tom Brady I
think he's unbelievable I just it's
surprising to me that he would have a
burst of sales like that it's just if
we're doing like franchise length that
makes sense
chi'lan Ramsey's entrance to training
camp today caught my eye because it made
me realize that we have a shift now in
the way of NFL social media the NFL was
behind the NBA for a long time
we're people doing cool stuff off the
field it's the reason that the left Co
PR was a thing like not a lot of social
media accounts we're really capturing
that it was people giving out their
division winners and people giving out
you know their hot takes and their
sleepers and they're overrated but the
NFL now is all about UGC user-generated
content and Jalen Ramsay entering
training camp when it happened on
Wednesday morning set Twitter ablaze and
it made me realize that I'm kind of a
Grinch Ian Rapoport was tweeting about
it I've seen shefter tweet about these
things and what it made me realize that
I'm jealous about with MBA Twitter is
that everyone on MBA Twitter has a role
woge does not tweet out memes shammes
does not send out gifts they are news
people there are mean people and meme
people in the NBA
there are gift people in the NBA there's
people that create their own content
there's people that create voiceovers
and in the NFL everyone just keeps
sharing the same things and I also just
didn't like the Jalen Ramsey content it
was a deist sponsor which more power to
Jalen
he pulled up in a fake Brinks truck
which I appreciate because GL and Ramsey
should be paid but I don't know maybe
I'm not the biggest haha Davis fan but
like I grew up with Reggie Wayne Reggie
Wayne pulled up to training camp in a
tank
Reggie Wayne landed on a practice field
in a helicopter Antonio Brown showed up
last year in a Rolls Royce from like the
1930s looking like Great Gatsby what I
don't what I realized it upset me was
when people start calling things epic
and legendary and I know this is a thing
on social media it's just like it feels
like all these reporters are like wow I
can put things on social media now and
be lit and I know that I'm being a
[ __ ] Grinch right now like I know that
and I wish anger was here to kind of
calm me down but I just started seeing
everyone share in the same video and I
was like man can you all you don't make
[ __ ] like connect can everybody start
putting out some content that's like
actually resonates with people but I I
appreciate Jalen trying to make an
entrance
I know like half the NFL reported on
Wednesday
I still have hope that a Antonio Browns
gonna do some awesome stuff
I still have hope that a number of these
other players like I won Odell to do
some crazy stuff but I don't think he
will but shout out the Jalen for trying
something but I realized that I'm a
Grinch because a lot of NFL social media
is starting to all share the same things
and it's making me feel dirty and if you
have a reason why share it with me add
Adam left go and let me know because I
have a feeling I'm just a Grinch but I
want to make sure all right Saul Kyle
fuller out there at Lake Tahoe
he is one of the young star quarterbacks
of the NFL we talked about how people
think that he looks like an NBA player
and which NBA player that is and then we
did the interview soon after Eddie
Jackson said they're coming for the 1985
bears which I thought was a lofty goal
but he talked about it that more right
now Kyle fuller
all right I'm gonna admit something to
the incredible 33% audience I walked up
to Kyle fuller
man I know your face I just can't
[ __ ] recognize you and that is the
plight of a football player but is it
also amazing that people kind of go I
think that's somebody but I'm not uh I
think I mean it probably is I think it's
something we may get used to I'm Esther
I mess with you a little bit because
they get him mixed up who else do people
call you
you said colwiz we got been getting
towel our like they'll be bringing the
book up for me to sign I'm like that's
not me or did you sign it though not as
I'm I would sign I couldn't do that with
any guy so I started messing with people
even then you know just going along with
it a little bit because it's funniest
you hit me with fuller and I'm like
brothers like eight of you in the NFL
right now - yeah but you're balling out
for the Bears you think how good is it -
you were already killed in your career
and then to have the team and Mack
coming how special was last year it was
really special you know we think about
Chicago that's that's the type of
football team that you did right you fit
the identity - right so he's a lot of
fun you know and it's the most important
part you know it all comes with winning
game so you know just want to try to
build on that this year that was a
really good answer by the way I like
that thank you Oh Eddie Jackson he came
out and we were actually laughing about
this the other day here's Eddie Jackson
going we're coming from the 85 Bears
yeah if I'm a fan of the Bears I go
let's go yeah what is it like when you
have a team in history that's kind of
always there and you're playing for the
same franchise I think I think that
speaks for our team you know I think at
this point that's our that's our goal we
want to we want to get to that you know
that level or that game you know that's
that's that's we got to uh you know know
strive for sure you know I think they
did a great job for us you know
you know a great team of great defense
you know just for something to go after
so you know but it's there so you take
it as motivation for sure under but not
like this looming thing no no no not at
all I think you know I speaks for spooks
Martine you know it he's a no perfect
guy that's what that quote to be coming
from you know so I mean that he could
have been up for Defensive Player of the
Year last yeah yeah yeah everybody knew
Khalil Mac was an incredible acquisition
was there a moment in practice or
anytime that you saw something that it
even kind of shocked you a little bit no
I mean I think we knew we knew the type
of player was and I think you know he
didn't disappoint when he came in you
know just the way he worked came in in
practice okay so the guy getting paid
the money here is work that sets the
tone for every yeah and you could tell
you know you could tell how you know
that's just you know gradually
throughout the year you know it just
stayed consistent and I just spread
throughout the whole team and I think
yeah that's that that ones who you know
a lot of our success random player
question for you when you're a guy and
people keep going he's the most
underrated player in the NFL do you take
that as a compliment or are you kind of
like I'm done with being called underage
because you had that title if I felt
like for like two years
right I don't I don't I don't take it
personally I don't really pay attention
to it it's like a compliment but it's
also like no I don't I don't so I don't
think anything of it yeah so you know my
you know I think you know individually
you know guys want to god an you know
work hard you be the best player they
can be and uh you know get better every
year you know so that's that's kind of
my opposed to it NFC North is incredible
this year yeah like we got Kyle Rudolph
out here on the budding green right now
Vikings are I think it'll bounce back
Green Bay all the injuries they gotta
Aaron Rodgers yeah and then I even think
Detroit yeah I mean when you got
Stafford you could put it anywhere yeah
I think it's a great it's a great
division to being right now I think you
might be them the deepest division up
already
I think that's good for us
just having that competition you know
like I said I said earlier every week
you know in the natural I leave isn't a
competition and you know it's but
without division games you know that uh
that competition you know you're there
to bring the best out of us can I ask
you a top three question
top three wide receivers that I'm not
saying they're the hardest that that
week you're like you have to mentally
get ready for them the most that I've
had to go against yeah
Kommandant in my rookie year holy crap
Julio oh and everybody else I put the
berry so those two what was just being
in tell me about faces cuz I will never
have to jam Calvin I'll never have to
run with Cal yeah just just a big guy
you know that can move and go up to get
the ball you know at that time is it
better in when I was a rookie so for
that I appreciate you a lot do you have
a message to bears nation out there
right now bear down bear down yeah
how [ __ ] fuller in the thank you thank
you so much for Kyle fuller again hit
him up and let him know that you
appreciate him here with the 33 percent
stay tuned again to the left coast show
social media accounts I am going to
start asking for people that want to
sign up so we can get a total number of
people that want to play fantasy I think
we're gonna do it on Yahoo and again my
man ezel is gonna be running in I want
to leave you guys with some goodness
some motivation and I got this email
from a listserv called the daily coach
and I wanted to share it with you
because I think that you guys could
appreciate him so I'm gonna read what it
says and then I'm gonna bid you guys
adieu in February of 1991
Bill Belichick walked into the Browns
facility on Bagley Road in Berea Ohio
and handed a piece of paper in his
smallish perfectly straight printing
that described exactly the kind of
football team that he wanted to build in
Cleveland the thin line three-ring
border paper essentially was the
beginning of the Browns way which
manifested into the patriot way some 10
years later the words read
big fast athletic mentally tough capable
of playing in any weather and can
control the middle of the field
simple precise and well thought out
clearly Belichick spent many years
thinking like a head coach in the coming
days he would provide detailed job
descriptions for every single person in
the football operation down to the ball
boys with the traits required for each
person there was no detail too small for
Belichick and all those off seasons in
New York he was with the Giants before
becoming a head coach we're spent
thinking about when I get my chance the
example Belichick set applies to every
walk of professional life from business
to sports to anyone with a competitive
spirit or anyone who wants to get their
chance it does not matter if you walk
along an NFL sideline or Wall Street or
a small group of people in an office
preparation in detail always shine when
your chance finally occurs if you have
dreams and ambitions for upward moment
for upward movement put pen to paper and
make a plan for when you will arrive and
how you will behave once you're there
there is no time like the present
to work on your future regardless of
your place on the companies or chart I
wanted to share this with you because I
think it's football related and I think
it's life related coaches we always hear
they show up with their binders of the
things they're gonna do and when they're
gonna hold practice and how they're
gonna do it not everybody wants the job
they have but you can start to work on
the job you want during the job that you
have I know that there's a lot of you
guys out there right now that are not
doing what you want and you're waiting
for your chance but what I'm telling you
is is that when you get that chance
you're not always gonna have the time to
finally come up with what you want a lot
of people have fear to put pen to paper
they're afraid to put down their plans
because they might not be good plans and
if they just keep it in their head when
they do write it down it will be good
I'm here to tell you that if you don't
start planning out what you want to do
and what you want to accomplish that
it's never gonna get done because that
that that dream might hit you that
chance might hit you and you might pass
it up
I have had people friends of mine that I
have known for years that want to do
stuff on this show and recently I said
hey man here's the deal
send me an audio clip do a minute
segment and send it to me and I'll see
if it's good and if it's not I'll tell
you to do another one and if it is maybe
I'll put it on and he has didn't send me
anything because I know that fear can
overcome people but what I'm telling you
is if you want to change your life put
that [ __ ] on paper put it on paper plan
it out set goals for yourself a lot of
people will distract themselves
daddy cigar glass of whiskey Netflix I
don't want to sound like Gary Vee right
now but we're really good at distracting
ourselves from doing the work that
scares us and what I'm telling you and
Rob Riggle said this last week don't be
afraid
lean into the fear because you might
realize damn I don't have any good ideas
and you're gonna need some so that's my
my ending note to you guys is really
visualize what you guys want in your
life put pen to paper like I'm telling
you right now that William ezel this
Saints fan the proud member of the 33%
that I'm letting him run the fantasy
league my man has been DMing me for
years he has a podcast I was a guest on
his podcast most of you guys know that
if you slide into my DMS I'm going to
respond I'm not as great as respond to
the people that say what advice do you
have for me I don't have time like you
guys are busy you know how busy I am but
if you guys come to me rod Simba reached
out to me recently and says hey man
loving the show do you need any more
music and I said you know what I might
know about this Mitchell pants key hit
me up the dude that makes all the
graphics and says hey man I'm thinking
about making a logo
alright don't and you know I'm gonna do
I'm gonna feature their work I'm gonna
talk about them on the show I'm gonna
I'm gonna put them into my circle and
people are gonna say hey who made your
music and then maybe I connect rod
cymbal with somebody and then all of a
sudden rod Simba's music career starts
going so when you reach out to somebody
for that chance reach out with something
for them I know I've shared this this
message with you guys before but put
your goals on paper and when you do
reach out give I don't want to keep
preaching I'm gonna stop I just love you
guys a lot and I know that there's a lot
of good people that listen to this show
and I want to give the 33 percent my 33
percent and sometimes it's wisdom I just
talked to interns that's why I'm
sounding like this right now but I want
to say thank you to Mike Vrabel for
talking about cutting his dick off thank
you to Kyle fuller for stopping by and
do in the interview there will be new
information for the l FGL coming up soon
but i want to say thank you to Nick for
role in the music appreciate you guys
very much we're gonna have more
interviews next week I think we're gonna
have Vince Carter I think we're gonna
have Kyle Rudolph
I think we're abjure d Nelson more
episodes of the new show are gonna be
coming out and pay attention because I'm
gonna have the rankings for wedding
dance circles I just want you to know
that the MVP of the NFL may have
messaged me that he heard that I'm doing
dance rankings and that he's really good
dancer that's how powerful the [ __ ]
33% is I [ __ ] love you guys and I'm
cursing a lot because I love you a lot B
well do well holla holla holla I'll talk
to you guys next week
[Music]